one of the great philosophical thinkers
who I particularly like and can see
myself working and teaching on for the
rest of my life and career as well as
reading and rereading and studying is
Plato and so I've been doing these these
more personal videos talking about my
own philosophical development and you
know who I got into when why all those
sorts of things for my viewers and
subscribers so I think that it's it's
about time that I do talk about Plato
and in some respects I've said in
certain forums that I could be
considered a bit of a plate inist and so
there's aspects of not just Plato but
also the Platonic tradition that I find
quite congenial in my own thinking but I
can't really call myself a Plato scholar
or a you know committed playtest as such
I'm just somebody who keeps coming back
over and over again you could say I met
sort of an intermediary level of both
commitment and competence when it comes
to to Plato and in my view that that's
actually pretty good
because Plato is a deceptively easy and
difficult author for a variety of
reasons that that also make his work
such a delight to read and to think
about so I suppose where I should again
is talking about how I got into Plato in
in the first place and interestingly
enough I got exposed to Plato back in
middle school and then high school you
know you would come across references to
Plato platonic forms you know archetypes
that sort of thing and it was all very
on-the-fly
none of it was in any systematic way
they didn't have us reading Plato's
texts or anything like that at the time
but it was it was part of what you
needed to know about in order to like go
through
history right and I think that my first
serious introduction to Plato came in
highschool I mentioned in a few other
videos and I'll probably do a video
specifically about this sometime that I
was very fortunate to have a substitute
teacher substitute for an entire
semester a little guy from Seattle named
mr. Lorenzo and I don't know his first
name he took over our sacraments class
after the nun who is was supposed to
teach it got sick and eventually
unfortunately died and he thought that
if he was going to teach about
sacraments he should teach Augustine
because he he was really into Augustine
and he thought well you can't really
teach August Eid effectively without
teaching Plato and as it turned out he
not only taught us a good bit about
Plato and that and they said well if
you're gonna study Plato you probably
need to know some Aristotle we did some
Aristotle he taught us about mantequilla
ISM and Gnosticism and all that that's
sort of cool stuff and then we finally
did Augustine and we had a little bit of
time left so he said well you know
Augustine was kind of a psychologist of
sorts so let's do some Freud and let's
do some young as well for comparison's
sake and so that was really great I I
really enjoyed that you know there was
he taught us about the allegory of the
cave he taught us about the notion of
the Platonic forms
he has debate about it in class so he
pursued things dialectically which is
very important because that's that's
part of the Platonic you know process
not just Socrates but Plato himself
thought that dialectic was incredibly
important and he also taught us about
this notion of the Demiurge that you
find in the Timaeus that then shows up
in Gnostic literature so that you know I
you know sort of filed that away in the
back of my head I had no intention of
going to college I went in the Army
while I was in the Army I bought books
on philosophy because I thought
philosophy was kind of cool in part
because of mr. Lorenzo because the other
actual philosophy course that I took in
high school was terrible
would have turned me off on philosophy
for good but I I bought books and they
talked about Plato I wasn't actually
reading platonic dialogues at that point
but you know I was learning about
Plato's ideas and then I get out of the
army I worked for a bit and then go to
college and so at Lakeland College
I took my very first semester there I
took intro to philosophy is I took some
other courses to writing and things like
that oh yeah in freshman Studies and I
think we read we read Plato's apology
perhaps in our freshman Studies class
but the main thing was in our intro to
philosophy class that's when I started
getting introduced to Plato and actually
reading what Plato had had written and
at that time I really was not in much of
a position to appreciate its depth or
complexity or subtlety but you know
there were some ideas and I was I was
working around at them and then of
course you know in an ethics class in
ancient philosophy class I was reading
more and more Plato and I enjoyed
reading platonic dialogues I think part
of that was part of what drew me in was
the dialogue form I like this idea that
instead of just having a rather dry
presentation of here's how it is
you know they would have people talking
back and forth about it which is you
know what we did back then those of us
who were intellectually inclined in a
culture that was you know not
particularly favorable to that you know
this area is you know much much better
in that respect now but when I was a kid
that really was not the case you know I
I read more and more and and I let the
ideas kind of work on me and I think
that's part of what you have to do with
Platonic dialogues there's there's quite
a few people who read them as if they're
gonna get everything out of it that
first reading and they're just gonna
like you know find the arguments or find
the main points and that'll be that
and then
they can assess Plato and Plato Plato is
great or Plato sucks because of this
right and that's just not the way you
read a platonic dialogue you don't have
to be all you know mystical and esoteric
and all that sort of stuff about it
either but you do have to like go
through it because these are complex
works of thought and art as a matter of
fact when you start reading Plato in the
Greek you'll find out just what a a
wonderful master of style he turns out
to be but anyway going back to before I
learn reekin I'm you know an
undergraduate I really enjoyed reading
Plato there were a lot of his ideas that
I couldn't you know fully entertain
because I think I had the idea that
philosophy was more about you know what
you could fully buy into and if you
couldn't fully buy into it then you
didn't really need to focus on and all
that much I was kind of in a queston
phase a searching phase myself but be
that as it may I really enjoyed spending
time with those those dialogues and some
of them I read and reread you know
multiple times you know the Republic for
example I remember as an undergraduate
reading the apology a number of times
the credo didn't buy it of course but I
really enjoyed reading it the Euthyphro
came up in our philosophy of religion
class and there were a few others as
well and then you know fast-forward to
graduate school
Plato was one of the people who figured
pretty heavily understandably so into
our comprehensive at the Masters level
and prelim reading lists and you know he
would come up quite a bit in in other
philosophers in in other contexts so you
really needed to learn quite a bit of
Plato in order to make sense of what was
going on in the rest of the
history of philosophy and so I you know
I devoted quite a bit of time to
studying Plato and the more you know
here's what I found the more that I did
that the more rewarding it became each
time that I would reread a platonic
dialogue I would find something that I
had missed before some connection
perhaps to another dialogue or an
implication of what was being said or
some little aside that I had ignored
before and now realized was important
and I can't say that I've actually
retained all that in my IDI from all
those years of reading and rereading and
teaching and studying or anything like
that but I can say that you know I I've
become convinced that Plato will always
reward a rereading and this became
particularly clear when I began reading
him in Greek and and I began reading
Plato in Greek in part because you know
when I first started studying Greek we'd
have little snippets of text here and
there that was first-year Greek right
and that was all you know learn the
grammar learn some vocabulary and then
you're thrown right into readings in
second-year Greek and you start out with
some fairly easy stuff
I remember we we read the credo and some
some other things that would read some
Lucien which was a lot of fun and some
other things as well that that first or
that second year the first year of
readings and then my third year I was on
my own by that there weren't a lot of
people making it through the Greek
curriculum at the time we started out
originally with 12 people by the end of
the first semester we had four four
entered the second semester two of us
proceeded made it to the end I proceeded
on to the next thing I don't know what
happened to the other the other person
but I had the opportunity to spend an
entire semester reading the symposium in
Greek with Rick Williams who was the
head of the
six department at the time and also if I
remember right the head of the Honors
Program really cool guy he was the guy
that first year Greek and he had been
reading the symposium and rereading it
for about 40 years at that point and the
reason why he kept going back to it was
not just because of all the funny you
know jokes and humor in it and plays on
words or the you know the depth of the
you know sort of the the the scope of
the great ideas in there whether in
Aristophanes speech or an in do to most
speech but it was because he said that
there were still questions left
unanswered for him that were raised by
this classic text and he he wanted the
opportunity to keep going back to it so
given a student who wanted to go through
it with him he he was very happy to do
that and we had some great discussions
we would sit there you know going
through the texts discussing it and
that's that's uh you know I think that
that's kind of a useful thing if you
ever get the chance to do that it's well
worth doing I'm not saying you have to
do that in order to read Plato there's
many many other great things you could
do as well but it certainly was was
wonderful for me to see somebody else so
on fire about it and you know I'll tell
you about an another interesting story -
about somebody who I like quite a bit
who is not a Plato scholar as such but
but rather works on medieval thinkers
there's a good friend of mine from st.
Anselm's College who when he was in
California he's quite a bit older than
me when he was in California and he had
to take philosophy classes it was all
just you know analytic philosophy is
like wow this this stuff is just
mind-numbing least Altaf iong and nobody
had told them that plato was actually
you know at the core of philosophy he
you know he got his degree and then he
was playing him as a musician and then
he happened to come across
Plato's dialogue somebody gave him a
book and said hey why don't you read
this stuff and he started reading it was
like this is philosophy oh my god what
have I been missing and he enrolled as a
graduate student and went on to earn his
degree and in philosophy and and you
know began teaching and and if it hadn't
been for Plato's dialogues that his life
would have taken a totally different
course but that's that's the power that
these sort of texts have I myself you
know there there are some platonic texts
I would say that I go back to more often
I try to make it a practice and I didn't
manage to do it last year but I did have
a sort of practice of making sure that
over the course of each year I go
through the entire Platonic corpus so
that I'm you know refreshing myself on
this and it's it's not a it's not a
laborious task I really enjoyed doing it
but I would say that the ones that I end
up focusing on the most are of course
the symposium and the closely-related
Phaedrus which is also about love but
also the the Republic you know that
that's a work that you know one of the
longest and some respects richest of
Plato's works I do like the early
operatic that means they don't achieve a
conclusion dialogues not just the you
know ones that they have you read the
Euthyphro all the apology and the the
Meno and the credo but also the ones
like the karma T's which is about
temperance and wisdom the law case which
is about courage you know those sorts of
things I really enjoy reading and
rereading and thinking about the
implications of them I also really like
the Protagoras and the gorgeous I have
to admit I I do like the you know the
later very in some respects more
systematic dialogues like the sophist
and the Statesmen and you know I also
like that the Timaeus I enjoy reading
through it just to see what he's doing
with cosmology and you know Natural
Science and the human body but I have to
say that it's it's probably the early
and middle dialogues that I enjoy the
most and that Isis on the most in
teaching and I there's a lot of stuff in
Plato often put in the mouth of Socrates
that I think is quite valuable you don't
necessarily have to buy into the
Platonic system and I don't think
anybody's really quite sure exactly what
the Platonic system itself is there's so
many varying you know ways of reading
Plato and reconstructing what would be a
systematic philosophy out of it that
it's it's always going to be a bit
controversial to endorse one over the
other and there are some things we can
definitely agree on Plato thought there
were forms right but there's a lot of
really great insights that Plato has
take for example the Platonic doctrine
of the forms right you don't necessarily
have to buy into exactly his view on
them or you know the forms being more
real than the things that we experience
in order to derive some benefit about
thinking about the fact that every
instance for example of Justice that we
see here in this world that we
experience that we find in ourselves in
our actions in our intentions is not
purely just it is not the form there's
some injustice lurking in there and and
it's meaningful to ask the question is
is justice itself unjust in certain
respects and to do the thinking about
this this sort of thing his discussion
about mythology and misanthropy and the
Phaedo something i keep going back to
sometimes bringing up for my clients and
in philosophical counseling a great
insight about how people
and this works even today you know sort
of like people become Nizam misanthropic
quite often by being overly uncritically
trusting and thinking other people are
good and then they get screwed over and
they're like man people are just all bad
and people do this with arguments or
with accounts or ideologies logo in the
Greek they you know you see these people
they they bounce from system to system
from approach to approach they've always
got the latest self-help book and that's
gonna totally straighten out their life
and then it doesn't then they're then
it's like a false friend and they're
like oh this is all nonsense you know
and eventually they become totally jaded
and cynical and you find him sitting at
the end of the barstool you know in the
middle of the day talking smack about
everybody and everything well you know
Plato saw that happening in his own time
and there's all sorts of other great
insights like that that that you can you
know find in Plato's texts and bring
up-to-date in the present day and I just
find you know that that sort of thing
really quite quite interesting I like
watching the progress of dialectic you
know the the questioning and answer and
weighing of things I don't always agree
and sometimes I think that Plato has
actually set up his dialogues so that
you as the reader should be saying wait
a second Socrates this guy should have
responded this way to you here's an
objection
I think Plato actually designed the
dialogues that way as a way for you to
exercise and develop your your intellect
they promote a dialogue that we can have
about the Platonic dialogues so it's
just wonderful stuff so you can tell
that I really enjoy Plato quite a bit
and that I think he's he's really well
worth reading and studying I guess for
those of you who you know either he
haven't read Plato before or you read it
and you had a negative experience with
it I would say you have to give it a
couple chances and you have to approach
it with not an open mind in the sense of
like just accepting whatever
he happens to say Plato doesn't want you
to do that but at least being willing to
entertain the idea that there's
something there so that's probably
enough about you know what it is that I
find valuable and Plato if you want to
leave comments about what you enjoy
about Plato that's quite all right
you've heard my take and that's that